angelica cugini is spending her work day
in the backyard trying to steer clear of
her family while she recovers from her
fourth bout of covid 19. i'm definitely
not scared of coven it's obviously a
nuisance while testing has largely
slowed wastewater data shows cases are
up pretty much across the country that's
in part thanks to omicron's highly
transmissible subvariant ba5 coupled
with the removal of most public health
measures we should still have been
encouraging people to continue wearing
the mask when they're in public this
week ottawa's top doctor expressed her
concern and asked people to reassess
their behaviors including wearing masks
indoors and outdoors in crowded spaces
but last week ontario's chief medical
officer of health said the province had
no plans to bring back restrictions a
similar sentiment heard in quebec
despite the rise in hospitalizations
there we do not need to reinforce
public health policies or mandatory
acting from for for the population in
the u.s there have been 90 million
reported coven 19 cases since the
pandemic began and in the last two weeks
infections have risen roughly 16 percent
statistics prompting cities like los
angeles to consider re-implementing
indoor mask mandates in san diego
masking is now a requirement for summer
school while new york's governor is
holding off for now but i'm going to
reserve the right
to return this policy if the the numbers
change but waiting until cases explode
defeats the purpose says this public
health expert who worries leaving it up
to choice won't work if you don't
actually put something in place and and
and in indicate to people and really
sell the message then you're not going
to get anywhere despite her reinfections
kugini who is fully vaccinated says she
would be happy to never wear a mask
again i think it's so much better the
way that we're doing it right now i
think definitely moving forward and
living with the virus is important the
path public health officials have now
put us on
for better or for worse jamie morocco
global news toronto